a fifth consecutive night of Burning
Anger in France
cars set on fire and looting in Paris
Street battles and tear gas fired in
Marseille flashpoints 2 in Lyon but less
intense apparently than the previous
four nights of unrest
[Applause]
the rioters kept in check by the
overwhelming presence of tens of
thousands of police mobilized Nationwide
and guarding famous landmarks
the riots were sparked by the shooting
of 17-year-old Niall M during a police
traffic stop in a suburb of Paris on
Tuesday
imagine if it had happened to my brother
in the street because he refused to stop
we should be safe with the police but
we're scared of them that is not normal
protesters said long simmering anger at
racial and economic inequality exploded
the police checked us at least four
times we are just here for justice we
are not here to break stuff
they mix everything up she's black and
therefore she must be like this he's
Arab so he is like this life is not like
that
the French Finance Minister said more
than 700 shops supermarkets and
restaurants had been looted or damaged
since Tuesday
facing one of the worst crises of his
presidency Emmanuel macron postponed a
state visit to Germany
in nantair where Naya lived and died
large crowds turned out for his funeral
on Saturday
the many mourners following his coffin
and continuing their calls for justice
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera
joining us now live from Paris is Al
jazeera's Bernard Smith Bernard the
violin says we've heard less intense
last night than it's been over the last
few nights bring us up to speed with the
latest first
fully as quieter in major Paris cities
overnight not least though because of
intense policing 45 000 police officers
deployed across France but mainly we're
talking about Paris Marseille and Leon
the three biggest french cities that
policing help in keeping a lid it seems
on the protests here on the
champs-elysees it was a call on social
media on Saturday night for protesters
to come out here and protest and that
and the here there was a large police
presence was police checking through
people's uh chatting through people's
bags and shops have been boarded up but
it is much calmer today there was a
mayor's office uh that was attacked
that's the main headline on French local
television but they've the the
authorities feel or hope that the worst
of the protests are over fully you're
standing Bernard on Francis famous
translations Avenue it's the beginning
of the summer holiday season very soon
in France how is this all affecting the
country's image
well this is that this is undoubtedly a
blow to France's image the
champs-elysees is this morning very busy
as it always is with Taurus this is the
most visited city in the world in the
most visited country in the world and
the French are really concerned about
how this looks overseas one of the main
stories on French television news last
night was the reporting of this story by
overseas media Emmanuel macron's already
had to cancel one state visit this year
that was King Charles that from the UK
was due to come in March but that was
canceled because of the pension protests
now macron's canceled a visit to a state
visit to Germany it looked it piles
political pressure on macron and we're
just a year away from the Olympics so
the government is really worried about
not just the social issues of what's
provoking uh the rioting but also the
image and the cost to France
internationally Bernard thank you very
much Bernard Smith live there in Paris